ja hallo jetzt bin ich hier auf dem
fahrrad unterwegs
schaut euch das an ja hallo haben wir
gesehen und jetzt sind sie hier beim
netz sind herzlich willkommen alles
weiter von der afg hallo hallo
vielen dank für die einladung ich war
schockiert als ich das gesehen habe war
ich schockiert
doch ich fahr rad aber ich telefoniere
war dabei nicht am fahrradfahren habe
beide hände am lenkrad das cost 25 euro
wollen sie mir die gleich geben oder
überweisen sie ist fortsetzung glück
nicht erreicht aber wurden sie noch
nicht mit dem mit dem clapton nähe wurde
noch nicht tun sie's ich würde auch
dicht halten wir müssen aber mal gucken
wieder gastes inter wechsel läuft aber
es war ein echt krass was muss ich denn
sagen dass es mir abknöpfen andere nur
die wahrheit das toll wenn sie einfach
voll und ganz aus sich heraus einfach
mit uns sprechen
die afg ist wahnsinnig erfolgreich im
netz die es viel erfolgreicher als viele
andere parteien
da werden cdu und spd auf nein durch
über 300.000 von auf facebook was machen
sie besser als angriff wir sind
authentisch
wir sind ehrlich das was da kommt kommt
ehrlich und echt von ihnen klar
schreiben sie selbst auf ihrer
facebook-seite ja zum teil ja sozusagen
sie sind potente und ehrlich dann habe
ich das hier von ihnen gesehen
hintergrund sehen sie eines der
sogenannten wilden lager von ihnen gibt
es unzählige in dieser stadt und
grenzregion zu frankreich und das sind
die bilder die sie in deutschland nicht
zu sehen bekommen
und das verstehe ich ehrlich gesagt
nicht weil die bilder bekomme ich in
deutschland zu sehen zum beispiel bei
dunja hayali die genau unter der selben
worte sein
das nicht gesehen oder warum sagen sie
so was ich finde es super dass dunja
hayali danach war ich war auch da weil
ich mich als politikerin informieren
muss über die gesamten bilden lager so
nennen die italiener das ja vor ort sind
schlimm aber wieso sagen sie dann dass
man das sonst in deutschland sieht man
sieht jetzt auch sonst auch in
deutschland beim zdf zum beispiel ja gut
aber dass das große thema gemacht wird
dass die menschen hier mit falschen
hoffnung ja hierhin gelockt werden durch
eine verfehlte willkommenskultur und
politik das wird finde ich nicht
thematisiert das ist ein kernthema der
afd
ich habe das hier im netz gesehen die
spur der welt kanzlerin durch europa ich
habe mich gefragt was meinen sie denn
damit ist es eine blutspur die angela
merkel durch europa zieht wollen sie mir
dass damit sagen
also das ist ja auch nicht ohne grund
nicht auf meiner seite es ist einfach
nicht mein duktus damit zu arbeiten ich
finde das total krass also sowas zu
sagen dass angela merkel nimmt blut spur
durch europa zieht ist für mich so ein
bisschen bei jeder normalen politischen
auseinandersetzung wie bewerten sie das
na gut ich meine wenn wir über eine
politische auseinandersetzung sprechen
ist es ja immer so dass man sich mit der
afg überhaupt gar nicht politisch
auseinandersetzen will dass sie immer
aggressionspotenzial und und das so wie
ich das jetzt verstehe ist in der tat so
dass wir durch die politik der offenen
grenzen
wir haben das eben auch beispielsweise
bei den anschlägen in brüssel und paris
gesehen dass die täter mit falschen
identitäten quer durch deutschland
gefahren sind mit
im kofferraum also das ist eigentlich
das was dieses bild suggerieren soll
und wir haben nun mal diese wir haben
nun mal diese probleme dass wir nicht
mehr ausschließen können dass durch die
politik der offenen grenzen eine
vielzahl von fehlern und terroristen
geben sich auch unter die flüchtlinge
gemischt haben
lassen sie uns weiter schon auf den auf
den wahlkampf ok ich möchte mit ihnen
auf plakate gucken und zwar hier auf dem
flyer traditionell uns gefällt's mercy
keine ahnung ist das nicht das
taiwanesische ja das ist teil man dann
haben wir hier die burkas nie wir stehen
auf bikini ist leider in südafrika und
was ich ganz besonders interessant fand
neue deutsche machen wir selber wir
haben fotografen angerufen die frau die
hier neue deutsche machen soll sie heißt
irina und kommt aus russland das cool j
foto aus russland ist so was schlecht
für die glaubwürdigkeit der afg oder
macht das nichts es ist ja kein großes
geheimnis dass ich jetzt nicht gerade
der größte fan von dieser kampagne bin
weil das ist auch so hier neue deutsche
machen wir selber jeder ist bei uns
herzlich willkommen der sich wirklich
auch in den deutschen arbeitsmarkt in
die deutsche gesellschaft einbringen
ich selber bin hier mit einer
schweizerin zusammen die
ursprünglich singhalesen ist also von
sri lanka kommt und ich meine ganz
ehrlich für mich kommt es einfach darauf
an dass die leute die deutsch sind ja so
dass das man auch die deutsche
staatsbürgerschaft annehmen kann wenn
man sich hier erfolgreich in den
arbeitsmarkt eingebracht hatten fertig
also das ist für mich ehrlich gesagt
kein kriterium
das ist nun zweiter gucken auf ein
sachthema die afg scheint die ängste
vieler deutscher aufzugreifen eine große
angst beantwortet sie aber ganz anders
als viele andere parteien die größte
sorge der deutschen voller wahl ist der
klimawandel hat eine studie
herausgefunden und in ihrem wahlprogramm
sagen sie aber klimawandel
wir glauben gar nicht dass der vom
menschen gemacht ist sie hat mit summa
cum laude promoviert glauben sie dass
auch dass der klimawandel nicht vom
menschen gemacht ist
es ist so es ist in der tat so eine
studie belegt je nachdem welchen
zeitraum sie betrachten das ist
menschengemacht ist und vor allen dingen
ist es stimmt es ja nicht ich schauen
sie der referenzwert ist wird er immer
am kohlen
hier kohlendioxid festgemacht an co2 das
ist nicht das gas was jetzt hier von
relevanz ist also diese gesamte klima
debatte ist völlig auch völlig
konstruiert und ich kann ihnen sagen ja
solange ganz ehrlich so laden in china
und den usa so viel abgase heraus
geblasen werden
er wird in deutschland werden wir
überhaupt keinen beitrag dazu da ist das
vermischt so ein bisschen zwei sachen
auf der einen seite ja auf der einen
seite sagen sie der klimawandel ist
nicht von menschen gemacht steht so in
dem programm auf der anderen seite sagen
sie ist ja aber auch egal ob der
klimawandel jetzt mensch gemacht die so
gar nicht weil die chinesen und die
amerikaner posten wie viel co2 in die
luft also ich finde also ich finde nicht
weil das erste ist wirklich es gibt
keinen nachweis dass es menschen gemacht
ist das ist ja es ist nun mal fakt die
überwiegende anzahl der forscher sagt
der klimawandel wie wir ihn jetzt sehen
der temperaturanstieg ist mensch gemacht
wenn man den zeitraubenden
untersuchungszeitraum groß genug wird
ich möchte ihnen noch mal zeigen was
potenzielle wähler auf der straße hier
in wedding von der position der afg zur
klima diskussionen denken also ich stehe
geschuldete da der mensch der sehr wohl
damit zu tun hat
lieber gott gemacht oder was wenn man
mir ein fan seit ich glaube daran nicht
dann kann ich einfach das nicht
akzeptieren also wenn jemand der
klimawandel wäre nicht menschengemacht
dann
werden die nicht auf diese welt weil das
ist eindeutig von menschen hergestellte
klimawandel ist ja keine glaubenssache
es gibt ja eigentlich auch schon die
wissenschaft her
na also über wissenschaftliche fakten
das wissen sie ja selber sie haben
wissenschaftlich gearbeitet haben
promoviert wie kann man dann bei
wissenschaftlichen fakten sozusagen auf
seine ganz auf sein ganz anderen schluss
kommen also churchill hat einmal gesagt
glaube keiner statistik die du nicht
selber gefälscht hast
und das gilt auch hier diese gesamte
klima hysterie
ja die ist an den haaren herbeigezogen
es gibt nun mal keinen validen nachweis
für den menschengemachten klimawandel
was ich mich gefragt habe
ganz gleich ob man jetzt den klimawandel
anerkennt oder nicht wenn man sagt man
muss die fluchtursachen für flüchtlinge
in den ländern in den herkunftsländern
bekämpfen müsste man dann nicht was
dagegen tun ganz egal
der klimawandel menschengemacht ist oder
nicht für mich passt es nicht zusammen
glauben sie dass das mit windkrafträdern
nur in deutschland zu bewältigen ist
wenn
wenn afrika immer weiter verwüstet also
wenn der anteil an lösten weiter zunimmt
das werden sie hier also sie merken ja
da schon an der größenordnung dass das
absolut absurd ist aber es wäre trotzdem
keinen grund nicht die ersten schritte
hierzu gehen
ich finde ich für mich passt vieles
nicht so ganz zusammen frau bildete sich
in ganz ehrlich sagen sie sie sind sehr
zivilisiert sie sind gebildet haben
promoviert sie sitzen dann hier und
vieles was ich von ihrer partei sehe
spricht eine ganz ganz angesprochen und
auch sie selbst online oft so eine
härter sondern ist eine eisige kälte
auch wie kommt das was so was empfinden
sie als kalt nennen sie mir ich empfinde
diese position zum klimawandel zum
beispiel als kalt obwohl es ja um die
hitze geht nämlich dass sie
beispielsweise sagen es wir müssen wir
müssen das nicht anerkennen wir müssen
hier weiter mit unserem diesel fahren
kann ich verstehe ja weil die ganze
diskussion um stickstoffoxid
referenzwerte auch völlig politisch
motiviert ist und auch jeder
wissenschaftlichen grundlage entbehrt
und da sage ihnen auch wissenschaftler
dass das eine politische diskussion ist
da werden sie jetzt natürlich wieder
sagen dass das gegenteil gilt aber ganz
ehrlich niemand kann mir eigentlich die
frage beantworten warum ja die
grenzwerte an der straße 20 fach
geringer sind als in einem büro
innenraum nein und das haben jetzt
verwaltet auch schon erzielt und damit
haben sie schon bei anne will alle in
den wahnsinn getrieben
unsere zeit ist leider um ich möchte sie
nicht abwürgen ich möchte ihnen
herzlichen dank sagen
und eine sache müssen sie mir nur sagen
dass so viele polarisierenden wahlkampf
was gucken sie sich zum entspannen auf
facebook an katzen videos
[Musik]
sagt alles weite spitzenkandidatin der
fdp zu gast bei nation herzlichen dank
für den besuch und ich klatschen rechner
zu